hey youtubers is Charlie time for some
Sherlock series for QA just like last
time I picked 20 of your questions from
the comments to answer in a video since
a lot of the questions were similar I
combined some of the answers to first
things first though congratulations to
all the winners from my giveaway and the
winners are Kennedy Barth
Liam Marshall Don Curtis Meg savvier and
Lauren Galloway you'll each get a copy
of the series three DVD or blu-ray your
choice if you are international or UK
I'll be giving you PayPal equivalent
I'll DM all you guys on your channels to
get contact info but everyone give them
a high five but don't worry if you
didn't win anything I'll be at VidCon
this summer giving away the Sherlock T
tins this is Moriarty
there won't be T in and they'll just be
empty but they're really cool all right
so let's answer some questions these
aren't in any particular order but here
we go
question number one geeky gal six four
four asks do you think Irene Adler will
make a full return in the next series
and do you think she has anything to do
with Moriarty's return yes she will be
back but the big question is is whether
or not it'll just be in the mine palace
or if it will also be in real life you
remember during saina 3 where he told
her you know get out of my head she's
never gonna get out of his head so
she'll always be present in each series
at least in the mine palace with respect
to Moriarty there is a theory that I've
seen that says that she is the one that
engineered that Moriarty clip just to
keep Sherlock from being sent away I
don't necessarily believe that but we
can't really rule anything out at this
point question number 2 incas rain asks
does Jeanine have anything to do with
Moriarty there were actually a lot of
people that asked different versions of
this question you know what is the
connection between Jeanine and Moriarty
if you look at valley of fear Sherlock
retired to Sussex Downs Jeanine bought a
cottage in Sussex Downs that story
features the first chronological
appearance of Moriarty so is there a
possible connection or has Jeanine
somehow related to Moriarty are they
just gender-bending her and she's the
brother if they're gender-bending the
brother character then it's possible
that she orchestrated the clip just as a
way to enact Moriarty's final plan she
would have had incredible access to
information by working with Magnussen so
there would have been an advantage to
having her inside of his operation it is
a very cool theory and they do have very
similar Irish accents question number
three apropos the wet snow asks did
Magnussen have anything to do with the
Moriarty clip it's possible that
Magnussen did have a fail-safe in place
in case anything bad happened with his
meeting with Sherlock but it's implied
that he was really good at remembering
things but it was really Sherlock that
was good at deducing things so I don't
think that Magnussen thought things out
quite as well as Sherlock would have
question number four hope Merritt asks
how long do you think that Steven Moffat
and Mark Gatiss have been planning the
Moriarty lives ending they actually plan
things really far in advance so they
probably knew what they wanted to happen
at the end of series two like right now
they already know what the story is for
series four and they're plotting out
series five that's how far ahead they
are they're years ahead question number
five Sommer Bradshaw asks I think
another famous Sherlock story they'll
probably use at some point is the
speckled band
high fives you're very well read for
anyone that doesn't know the speckled
band' is one of Sherlock's locked-room
mysteries remember during saina 3
whenever Sherlock claimed that the case
of the bloody Guardsman was the best
locker room mystery ever that was a
reference to a story like speckled band'
in actuality it's a really short story
but it takes place on an estate called
Stoke Moran which could be used as
connective tissue to the Sebastian Moran
character so even though Sherlock does
not believe in coincidences a lot of
things that end up getting the same name
just because Conan Doyle was really bad
at naming things question number six
lady loves music one asks could Mary
still die in series four do you think
we'll see young Sherlock again do you
really think we'll have Professor
Moriarty and will there be any
consequences of Sherlock being a
murderer now I don't think that muffin
and Gaydos would kill a mother and her
unborn child but I do think it's
possible that Mary will be sent away and
she and baby Watson will just be
separated from John with regards to
Professor Moriarty I don't ever recall
the word professor being attached to
Moriarty in series 1 or 2 so I'm leaving
myself open to that possibility the
possibility that Jim for my tea is
really the brother James Moriarty and no
there won't be any more repercussions
from Sherlock being a murderer the
government basically washed their hands
of that when they sent him off on that
trip and if he slays the dragon of
series 4 I think that they'll be
indebted to him so they'll kind of sweep
everything else under the rug question
number 7 the delicas asks what I want to
know is whether those bank robbers with
clown masks will play a bigger role in
series 4 or not they did kind of drop
the red-headed league plot during empty
hearse
I definitely think there'll be a
referenced in series for the red-headed
league was one of the stories from the
Canon that I predicted could be used and
we never did really find out what
happened to them after Donovan arrested
them so
possible that they could come back they
were a relatively minor plot though so I
don't expect them to be too big but they
could always come back in one of the you
know lesser story it's not the
overarching story of Series four but
just one of the episodes question number
eight Ivy Ellen asks if Mycroft is the
clever one then why does Mycroft depend
on Sherlock for help when things go bad
this is actually a fun one
Mycroft is the laziest smart person you
have ever met he never leaves the
Diogenes Club Mark Gatiss his version of
the character is a lot more active
though but still they're just honoring
the character in the Canon by having
Mycroft pass all the dirty work so to
speak on to Sherlock that's why during
empty hearse whenever Mycroft went to
rescue Sherlock from the Serbian prison
it was such a huge deal because the real
Mycroft and Kanin would have never done
that question number 9 x2 515 asks I'd
like to know who the new villain is and
why he decided to use Moriarty's face to
present himself also what do you think
is gonna happen when the baby is born
will Watson and Charlotte keep running
around London will Mary join them it's
most likely that the villain is a true
Sebastian Moran character someone who is
like Moriarty's Watson and they're just
using his image to strike fear in
England remember everyone learned that
Moriarty was the real villain during
empty hearse so if you were still alive
it would make everyone really scared and
yes
Sherlock and Watson will still be a team
clueing for looks mary will probably be
stuck in the hospital though if she does
end up giving birth during series 4 it
really depends on what the timeline is
series 4 is going to be series 3 kind of
jumped around in time so you know Mary
went from being not pregnant to super
pregnant so series 4 could take place
over to the course of a couple days or a
couple months you know we never know
question number 10 Helle Rochester asks
if Moriarty is dead what kind of villain
will we see and what will they do if
Moriarty is dead the real villain will
just be using the image of Moriarty to
misdirect Sherlock Moriarty is like the
dragon Mycroft was talking about a
figurehead for Sherlock to slay so the
evil plan could be anything you know
either destroying the government or just
stealing an ungodly amount of money the
real value of Moriarty at this point is
just scaring the hell out of the
government and everyone question number
11 and Eddie Bertrand asks I would
really like to know what happened to the
other Holmes brother so you're talking
about Sharon furred he's the theoretical
older brother of Sherlock and Mycroft
Mycroft stateman made it sound like he
was using said you know other one as an
example of not being sentimental
so either something really terrible
happened to that
brother or he's dead there is also a
very far-fetched theory that Stephen
Moffat will bend canon to make Moriarty
that third brother question number 12
Alondra guards asks what do you think of
Matt Smith possibly appearing in one of
Sherlock's episodes that would be
awesome I don't think it's gonna happen
but Matt Smith actually auditioned for
the role of Watson before Martin Freeman
was brought in but Steven Moffat said
that he was too much like Benedict
Cumberbatch in the series would not work
with two Sherlock Holmes's somewhere on
the internet I'm sure there is a Matt
Smith Sherlock audition tape I dare you
to find it question number 13 awkward
cacti asks I hope Cumberbatch will keep
coming back for more Sherlock both
Benedict Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman
have signed out for series four and
they've already said that they'll keep
making it as long as the BBC wants to
pay for it the only hard part is just
scheduling around all the movies they do
they are two of the most popular actors
available right now that's actually what
they're trying to do right now they're
trying to find time to shoot series four
so they haven't confirmed a start date
question number 14
Beebop the great asks I've heard rumors
that series 4 could air as soon as late
2014 any chance that that's true or just
wishful thinking yes that's definitely
wishful thinking they can only do that
if they finish filming all the episodes
by the beginning of the summer so that's
like June it takes a couple of months to
edit everything and add the music so I
would plan for another January first
premiere we'll probably find out when
it's gonna start shooting in the next
couple of months so once we know that we
can start guessing whenever series four
is actually gonna premiere question
number 15 nephew Jared asks what happens
when the source material runs out will
muffin and gayness just create new and
original Sherlock Holmes stories it's
most likely that they'll just combine
elements of different stories to make
new ones they can still operate within
the framework of the Canon and just
change names and events to keep things
fresh to a large extent stories are only
inspired by Conan Doyle's writings
they're never literal adaptations you
know beat for beat that just means that
they'll Bend can in a little bit and
they draw from a lot of different
sources not just the original novels
question number 16 art and Jacob asks so
big question for you is which villain
would make the most sense for the next
series and also do you think that Mary
could also be a villain no I don't think
that mary is the villain they've kind of
already explained her character but I do
think it makes the most sense for a true
Sebastian Moran character to surface or
my second opinion is is that the real
Professor Moriarty will surface I know a
lot of people really want
the original moriarity to come back but
that would require some really complex
explanations for how we survived that
gunshot wound and whether or not was
real and what happened on that rooftop
after Sherlock jumped off question
number 17 Amina Mae asks since the
writers seem to be borrowing a bit from
William s baring Gold's wonderful book
on Sherlock Holmes do you think that
they'll widen their sources to include
some of the many pastiches that have
been written about Holmes in the past
including the sir pond series yes they
even use some of the bits from the old
Sherlock Holmes movies that were
originally part of Conan Doyle's
writings so they draw from all think
Sherlock Holmes not just the original
stories so anything's up for grabs so if
there's other Sherlock source material
then you can look to that for more ideas
question number 18 Leah smiley face asks
will series 4 have small standalone
mysteries or will there be a giant
overarching theme I actually really want
to believe that the mystery of Moriarty
lives will take all of series 4 to
unravel it would be a major tease to
have it all explained in the first few
minutes that being said both the idea of
Moriarty and Magnussen were teased over
the course of each series so you could
argue that all the episodes are always
connected so yes it will be one giant
mystery kind of standing over you know
several small mysteries question number
19 Maggie Leigh asks is there any crazy
way that Moriarty could be the older
brother do you see there's a chance the
older brother may appear in series 4
thanks thank you so I kind of mentioned
this theory about Moriarty being the
older brother and a previous answer but
I think it's a little too far-fetched I
think that Moffat wants you to think
this series 3 will be like one large
internal Sherlock family battle that
does sound interesting the idea of you
know Holmes versus Holmes but I really
do think that in the world of the show
that older brother is a nonentity so no
I don't think the older brother theory
is gonna pan out question number 20 and
last one Mirren cope and all asks are
there any characters from the original
stories that you would like to see in
season 4 I really just want to see Irene
come back in a real way not just in the
mine palace I can't wait to hear or make
fun of Sherlock's relationship with
Jeanine
they may not have had sex but I am
guessing that he ran a couple of the
bases Arthur Conan Doyle once said that
the only real joy women bring to Holmes
is in the problems that they bring him
to solve so what I really want to see is
Irene or a new woman from the Canon
bring my problem that's so incredible
that it's better than sex that is one
question that I'll put to you guys right
below in the comments
what is that one
problem that would be so big that for
Sherlock it would be like having sex it
would be so enjoyable and do you think
that that will be the problem that he'll
have to solve during series 4 the big
overarching problem so if you guys
didn't see it I kind of teased the idea
that I'm gonna be doing a weekly
Sherlock video called the weekly
Sherlock I know very imaginative be sure
to subscribe to get it it's just gonna
be like anime club it'll be you know
weekly themed Sherlock video with you
know anything Sherlock so leave your
suggestions about what you want to see
in that in the meantime you should also
check out black sails and the Musketeers
which I both started doing videos for
they're actually gonna be a lot of fun
right now click here for my series 4
predictions and click here for my review
of episode 3 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives